BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: All
right, hi, everyone.
And welcome to this segment
of today's discussion
here at Google about
gender equality
and women's empowerment.
I'm Brigitte Gosselink.
I'm part of google.org which
is Google's philanthropic arm.
And I'm joined here today
by Gary Catona and Aubrey
Logan, who are here to premier
the song, "My Voice Matters,"
today on YouTube Live.
So I thought I would just give a
quick introduction to Gary, who
has been here at Google before.
Welcome back, Gary.
GARY CATONA: Thank you.
Nice to be here.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: So Gary's
insights into human voice
have established him as a guru
and scientist of the voice.
His revolutionary
voice-building system,
known as the Catona
Method, earned him
the title, the Maestro
of Voice and a reputation
as a rebel in the field
of vocal development.
We like rebels here,
so you will be at home.
He has taught some of
Hollywood's most successful
singers and entertainers,
names that you know well,
Whitney Houston, Andrea Bocelli,
Seal, Steven Tyler, Usher,
Shakira, Robin Thicke, Lorde.
I feel like perhaps
every Grammy maybe
is attributed to
you with that list.
And today he's
committed to teaching
his voice-building
system to the world.
So, Gary, thank you so much
for being here with us today.
GARY CATONA: Thank you.
Nice to be here.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK:
So, obviously,
this list of singers you've
taught is quite impressive.
And you are known for this
innovative voice-building
system.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about the system?
I understand it's pretty
scientifically based.
Share a little bit about that,
and what makes it different.
And kind of what's
at the crux of it?
GARY CATONA: Well, I call
what I do voice building.
And I think that
name says it all.
I have developed a way
of building the voice.
Think of the voice in
terms of its musculature.
When you speak or sing,
you're using muscles.
I developed a way of
exercising those muscles that
maximize the potential
in those muscles,
and I could literally
build a voice.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: I
think later today you're
going to show us a
little bit of the method.
But can you talk a
little bit about what's
going on in the method that you
use, sort of scientifically,
physiologically.
You talk about it a muscle.
What about what you
developed is different
and helps to actually do that
building that you talk about?
GARY CATONA: Well, most teachers
think of the voice as something
that you're born with.
Right?
You have, like, you
have brown eyes,
and you have a
certain kind of voice,
a certain kind of hair color.
What I've discovered is that
the voice is a potential.
And because it's
controlled by muscles.
So I've developed
a way of isolating
the muscles of the voice
box and the throat,
and building those
muscles in such a way
that you build power, resonance,
and range into the voice.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: So it's
possible I could learn to sing,
after all.
GARY CATONA: It's possible.
Not a guarantee.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: All right.
So, obviously, this has
been your life's work.
What's brought
you to this topic,
to really getting involved
in women's empowerment?
And how has your work,
if at all, influenced
the way that you think
about this particular topic
today that we're
talking about today?
GARY CATONA: I have a surprising
answer for you on that one.
Would you believe that
my first intuition
about the idea of a
voice having significance
began with none other
than Muhammad Ali.
He was on my first
students years ago.
When he was promoting
peace throughout the world,
and talking about
racial discrimination,
and I was working
with him, because he
had a vocal difficulty.
He had Parkinson's
syndrome, which
reduced the power of his voice.
And, in building
his voice back, we
had many, many
moments of discussion
about what a voice is.
And he would often say to me,
he say, Gary, what I want do
is raise my voice.
Because I know that I gotta
raise-- we gotta raise
our voices.
And he said that over,
and over, and over to me,
and it stuck with me.
Through the years,
as I began working
with a whole variety of people,
some very famous people,
and realizing how significant
the voice really is,
it was only a matter
of time before I
began thinking about this idea
of everybody's voice matters.
It's not just Muhammad
Ali, or Whitney Houston,
but everybody has a voice.
Everybody has a potential.
And if you think of the
voice as a metaphor.
Right?
Your voice, you
raise your voice.
Your voice is
really who you are.
When you speak, when you
express yourself, when you sing,
you're expressing your essence.
Why do you think you
hear this all the time?
Raise your voice for this.
Raise your voice for that.
Because it really is that.
It really is the
essence of who you are.
So that was the origin
of "My Voice Matters."
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK:
And so you and Aubrey
co-wrote the song that we're
about to hear Aubrey perform.
Can you just talk a little
bit about the song itself,
the motivation behind it, and
what you hope people take away
from the sun when they hear it?
GARY CATONA: Well, as I said,
over the past couple years
and working with a whole variety
of people, including people
with dysfunctional
voices, this concept
of the meaning of the
voice came into my mind.
And then I-- believe it
or not-- I was teaching.
I was teaching a
student and talking
about how important
the voice is,
and this phrase "my voice
matters" came to me.
It was an interesting idea.
My voice matters.
Very clever, and it says so
much-- integrity, strength,
power, self-affirmation.
So I took the idea to my good
friend, an incredible musician,
Nick Milo.
I said, Nick, I have this idea
for a song, "My Voice Matters."
What do you think
we can do with it?
So we came up with
a musical idea.
We worked on it,
worked on the lyrics.
And we fashioned a
really cool song.
And then we realized the
song wasn't quite right.
It was great, but not
as great as it could be.
Lo and behold, Aubrey Logan
walks into the picture-- one
of my students,
one of the greatest
voices I've ever taught.
And she also happens to
be an exceptional musician
and songwriter.
And we invited Aubrey to come
in and to, you might say,
complete the song.
And she made a major
change in the song,
and we have this masterpiece
that you should download,
everybody listening in.
Download, because the money's
going to the charities.
So it's important you
download the song.
Go to makemyvoicematter.org,
download the song,
and make your voice matter.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: Aubrey,
when you first heard the song
and came in to complete it,
what drew you to collaborating
on this project?
AUBREY LOGAN: I
think the concept
of having this panel
here today, that
spoke before we came
here together today,
I heard that Aimee
Mullins was coming.
I heard that Melissa was coming.
I heard that these
ladies were coming today
to speak about what
they've been doing
and what their life's work is.
And I realized that
these are powerful women
from all over the world.
And I've been told before,
even as a little kid,
you talk really loud.
I said, oops, I
didn't know that.
And so, maybe I
suppressed that later on.
But I realized, when I
heard the title the song,
"My Voice Matters," it kind
of made me pay attention.
GARY CATONA: It
resonated with you.
AUBREY LOGAN: It did.
Thank you.
It resonated with
me, and so, when
I learned what this event
today would be about,
and what we would
be celebrating,
and what the
charities were about,
it gave me a lot of inspiration
to write some verses.
And you'll hear those
a little bit later.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: Great.
Well, Gary, I think I'll
turn it over to you.
Gary is going to
demonstrate some
of his voice-building techniques
with Aubrey, who actually
knows how to do them
and has a great voice,
and then with the rest of us.
So bear with us here.
I'll turn it back
over to you all.
GARY CATONA: OK, here's
what we're going to do.
We're gonna give everybody
watching this program
a chance to experience what it
means to have your voice built.
The same exercise that
Whitney Houston has used,
Andrea Bocelli, and
countless other people.
So what I'm going to do is
give Aubrey a voice lesson,
a small version of
the voice lesson.
Then we're going
to have her sing.
But I want you to watch
this, and you get the idea.
When I talk about the
musculature of the voice,
you'll get the idea
of what I'm talking
about when you hear her voice.
You ready, Aubrey.
AUBREY LOGAN: Yes.
GARY CATONA: Don't screw up.
AUBREY LOGAN: OK.
GARY CATONA: Oh, ah, oh.
[PLAYING NOTES ON KEYBOARD]
AUBREY LOGAN: [SINGING]
[SINGING]
GARY CATONA: So you're
hearing muscles stretch.
That's what you're hearing.
All of that tone, how
rich and full it is,
that's because we're accessing
the musculature of her throat,
and you can hear it.
[PLAYING NOTES ON KEYBOARD]
Same thing.
AUBREY LOGAN: Same thing?
[SINGING]
GARY CATONA: Excellent.
OK.
[PLAYING NOTES ON KEYBOARD]
Ooh, ah, ooh.
AUBREY LOGAN: [SINGING]
GARY CATONA: Raise your voice.
[PLAYING NOTES ON KEYBOARD]
AUBREY LOGAN: (SINGING)
Ooh-- Ah-- Ooh--
[PLAYING NOTES ON KEYBOARD]
(SINGING) Ooh-- Ah-- Ooh--
GARY CATONA: That ain't nothin'.
[PLAYING NOTES ON KEYBOARD]
AUBREY LOGAN: [SINGING]
GARY CATONA: If that's not
female empowerment, what is?
AUBREY LOGAN: I've never
heard you say that in a lesson
before.
Learn something new every day.
GARY CATONA: You scared me
every lesson, that's why.
So what I want to do,
believe it or not,
is give you the chance of
doing a few of the exercises
along with me.
AUBREY LOGAN: Can you tell
them about the vowels?
GARY CATONA: About
the what, now?
AUBREY LOGAN: Tell
them about the vowels
so they know what
we did, just now.
GARY CATONA: Yeah, OK.
Thank you for that.
AUBREY LOGAN: Yeah.
GARY CATONA: I use the
vowel sounds like barbells.
Think about it.
When I go, (SINGING) Oh--
What you're hearing
is a vowel sound
stretching the throat muscles.
We use those vowel
sounds in a skill that
exercises the vocal muscles.
But all you people
listening in, I
want you to do a few of
these exercises with me.
Let's try it together.
OK?
Look.
[PLAYING NOTES ON KEYBOARD]
I want all of you to
do this-- even up here.
Don't be afraid.
Everybody out there, look.
[SINGING] Here we go, go.
Everybody.
EVERYONE: [SINGING]
[PLAYING NOTES ON KEYBOARD]
GARY CATONA: Big
breath, here we go.
Strong.
EVERYONE: [SINGING]
[NOTE ON KEYBOARD]
GARY CATONA: (SINGING) Oh-- go.
EVERYONE: [SINGING]
GARY CATONA: We should
start a choir here.
It sounds really good.
[PLAYING NOTES ON KEYBOARD]
Look, look at me.
One more time, look.
(SINGING) Oh-- oh.
Here we go, go.
EVERYONE: [SINGING]
GARY CATONA: Fantastic.
Fantastic.
AUBREY LOGAN: So you're shaping
the vowel in your throat.
It's not just in your mouth.
GARY CATONA: Any potential
Whitney Houstons out there?
Anybody?
OK, now the excitement begins.
Aubrey Logan is going to
sing our hit song, "My Voice
Matters."
And, as I said before,
these charities
will receive the benefit
of your generosity,
so please download the song.
OK?
And there are tee-shirts there,
too, if you're interested.
But here is Aubrey Logan's
"My Voice Matters,"
written by Nick Milo, Aubrey
Logan, and Gary Catona.
VOICE ON BACKUP TRACK:
One, Two, Three.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AUBREY LOGAN: (SINGING)
I can feel it.
It's alive.
Through the raging
cacophony survived.
There's a voice
in me unmistakably
to make somebody know their
worth, to set somebody free,
to tell her she can
change the world.
I know I've got to
see my voice matters.
My voice matters.
Feel the heart is waking.
Feel the world is awake.
My voice matters.
Your voice matters to me.
It's the sound we've
listened for forever.
There's a burning in my soul.
There's a story that's
waiting to be told.
Oh, they may not
see the fire yet,
but they can smell the smoke.
Well, they may not read
the book right now,
but I know something spoke.
My voice matters.
Feel the heart is waking.
Feel the world is awake.
My voice matters.
Your voice matters to me.
It's the sound we've
listened for forever.
Baby, sing it out.
Let it rain.
Oh, the worst thing
that can happen
won't undo the mark you'll make.
I dare you to say,
my voice matters.
My voice matters.
Feel the heart is waking.
Feel the world is awake.
My voice matters.
Your voice matters to me.
It's the sound we've
listened for forever.
Hear the sound.
We've wanted this forever.
GARY CATONA: Bravisimo.
AUBREY LOGAN: Thank
you, everybody.
GARY CATONA: Aubrey Logan.
I think our lovely charity
people have a few words to say.
AUBREY LOGAN: Fantastic.
OISIKA CHAKRABARTI:
Thank you, so much.
Thank you so much for this.
I'm Oisika Chakrabarti
from UN Women,
and please download this song.
Your contributions will
go to UN Women, which
is the UN's entity on
gender equality with offices
in 100 countries, and work
that goes to advance women
and girls across the world.
Thank you, so much.
PANELIST: Thank you very
much, Audrey and Catona.
Everyone, please download
this song, and help us
eradicate malaria in Africa.
Thank you.
MELISSA GOODMAN: Hi everyone.
Thank you, Aubrey,
that was beautiful.
I'm Melissa Goodman from the
ACLU of Southern California.
Please, please
download the song.
Part of your contribution
will help us.
We help defend your
constitutional rights
and your civil rights, including
your right to gender equality.
We work in the courts,
in the legislatures,
in the field of public opinion,
fighting for gender equality
from employment, to the
criminal justice system,
to the rights of
working families,
to ending gender violence.
Thank you.
BRIGITTE GOSSELINK: Wonderful.
Well, thanks to everyone
who participated today,
our panelists, to
Aubrey, to Gary, who's
building all of our voices,
as well, Hala Kazim,
and Aimee Mullins, who
spoke on our previous panel.
Thanks so much, and for any more
information, and to download
the song as you've
been asked, go
to makemyvoicematter.org and
find more information there.
Thank you.
Woo hoo.